welcome back to episode 9 of this C++
beginner series in this series I'm going
to talk briefly about classes and what
they are and how he used them I chose to
do this off camera because well it was a
little more complicated than the others
so I thought I'd just do it and then I'd
run down the code and show you the
changes usually when people make classes
they do them in a completely separate
file we're sticking with just one file
of the same main dot CPP so in this case
we're gonna go ahead and build our class
within this file and then we'll run our
main using our class we named our class
calculator and to use your class you do
have to instantiate it just like
instantiating a float or double or an
integer so the name of the class then
you give it a name for the one you're
gonna use and then from there on the
program is this essentially the same we
have our is running bull to check we
want to keep going and then while is
running we do calc run and this does the
exact same thing as our program did
before except now it's all handled
within a class and then to see if we
want to keep going in our while loop I
made a check of user wants to continue
that returns a boolean and it
essentially does the same thing but now
as you can see our main is very small
and if we had everything abstracted out
this would be really simple to look at
for another user than they would just
have a few questions like all right
let's look at how the calculator and run
functions built but if it just works
they might not need to the hope one of
the points of this is when you're
editing and updating your code you can
isolate it down to sections to work on
say I want to improve my checker user
wants to continue function you can do
that if I want to improve my calculator
I can do that and you just go work on
the class and you don't have to touch
the main so that way if you have a lot
of different people working on a lot of
different pieces everyone can kind of
improve little pieces of it and not step
on each other's toes all the time ok so
let's take a look at our calculator
class so the way you make a class
you start but with the keyword class and
then you give it a name its traditional
to start it with a capital letter and
then you do a set of brackets and you'll
see the ending one down here it does end
up with a semicolon and you have what's
called C what are these called
I think it's visibility maybe I can't
remember exactly but you have public
private and protected sections public
sections are visible and usable to
anybody instantiating your calculator
class private sections are not you won't
be able to see these from your
instantiation so if I tried to look at
first number second number I wouldn't be
able to see them the point of that is
these these aren't supposed to be
touched by the end user these are used
from within your class to handle the
stuff it does so I started out calling
run so first of all when I instantiate a
calculator it calls this default
constructor sets first number second
number and choice to their default
values and those are all private
variables that it needs to set to some
defaults then this here is called a
destructor it's what happens when the
your instantiation goes out of scope it
calls this destructor as you can see I
don't have it doing anything special but
you can if you want by default of course
it will deallocate all your standard
variables but if you cut other things in
here that it's not gonna handle getting
rid of automatically or if there's
special things you want to run when your
class goes out of scope or deletes you
can put that here in the destructor in
these brackets now our run as you can
see this is a big section of what used
to be our main is now well when I first
run it sets choice to invalid then it
starts our wild loop just like before
there's really no difference from that
big chunk of code it used to be our main
in the previous type episode now it's
just
this one line so there's the end of run
as you can see it just gets an entry
about what we want to do ask for the
numbers but now when we call get
injuries we no longer pass variables
into it they are private and already
ready to go and there's our good entries
it is also a private function so you
can't call that from the calc directly
you have to call run and let it do its
thing and well that's pretty much it for
getting started with classes so you
basically can build up a object that
handles all its internal states and
takes care of itself and that's sort of
the point of classes as well well also I
also turned the end part of our program
which used to be just these lines and I
put that into a function as well and now
rather than setting is running it just
returns two or false that way to connect
I can have it ask the question when this
function is called and it returns true
if they hit yes keeps his running true
it returns false if they say no or
anything anything other than yes okay
well I hope this helps and thank you for
watching another tutorial I hope you're
getting the hang of C++ so we have any
questions leave them down below don't
forget to give this a like if you learn
something and or enjoy the video where
you think others could it does help the
YouTube algorithm and get my videos seen
and until next time have a good one keep
coding